it's gonna be extraordinary
you're gonna get ready to leave and then
your heart is gonna race you're gonna
have all kinds of
fantasies and imaginations about what
this thing's gonna be none of them are
gonna be right it's gonna be totally
different whenever you get there
and here's the thing i can hear your
heart through the phone line when you go
back and see your family
right
man you're gonna hug like you haven't
hugged and you're gonna cry like you
haven't cried and you're gonna see
people and they're gonna be old and
wrinkly or beautiful
and are all three
and
i know your grandmother is
blind but she is gonna hug you in a way
that you know she'll be able to see into
your soul and she will run her fingers
all over your kids faces
it will be a different reunion but it
won't be a bad one it'll be a beautiful
one right and you've imagined this day
for 20 years right
now we're gonna we're gonna take the
next step forward the lighter load and a
lighter load in a light load